so there was a liquor company that came
to us I wish I could remember who it was
and they had created a word it was a
word that didn't exist it was a made-up
word that was here he was here yeah the
word was far foof barfoo far foof okay
good thing they didn't tell me they were
gonna they were gonna pay that I believe
it was at least a million dollars and
the premise was for three months you
were just supposed to weave the word
into the fabric of the show farfel
farfel phooey
like I would say in other words I would
make the word far foof cool yeah Gary
you really fall for that one you fart
flute fat yeah and you're supposed to
would say what is that and then that's
when the air campaign starts robbing and
then I really look like a tool right
like far foof instead of hey now I guess
far food they never said what it meant
the whole idea was it so it's a word
that can mean anything anything with God
can you imagine and then Robin looking
at me with disdain
Robin far food it's not even a funny
word far food what do you do it over
there I would have said to him
[ __ ] far foof Ronnie said ash trees yeah
ash tree so solemn that word we're
already we're already down the pike with
that one I think the premise was that
they can't use as treats in the TV ads
that they raw like outside of here new
ash treats whiskey shrieks shrieks
shrieks do you wanna do do we could have
something to do instead of dude Astrix
du du du that would work I'm telling you
dude